hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again
today's gonna be a bit of a longer video
and it's something I've been cooking up
for a little bit
foreigner year four is approaching and
before that of course we had twelve
seasons of content and seeing as I've
played and uploaded content throughout
all those twelve seasons I thought it
would get my personal take on every one
of the seasons going through everything
that had happened throughout that season
and then ranking it in a tier list a few
disclaimers though this will be going
over details and stuff that happened
within that season not every single my
new detail will be covered but the big
stuff especially will be mentioned and
also this will be about stuff that
happened throughout the season like I've
stated so like in this season for
example season twelve we've gotten a lot
of information about year four even
though this stuff happened in season 12
it isn't coming out in season 12
therefore it does not count towards the
tier list it is stuff only that came out
and released during that season but
starting off we have season 1 and that
was the release of for honor we had
twelve characters three factions a few
game modes and we still have
customization but of course not as much
as we have today and we only had up to
purple gear I believe and I think the
max rank was rough twenty or thirty
whatever one was the highest at the time
which was the default the same season
also had the leaks of Centurion shinobi
and Highlander like I said this won't
influence the tier list but I'm just
letting you know that for some
information this is also the first of
many cosmetics like ornaments battle
outfits and weekly content that we'll be
having in the near future whereas every
season on this list is gonna be changing
the game for better or worse season one
was the beginning and it didn't really
change anything so therefore it was kind
of like laying the groundwork out for
the game which is why I'm just gonna put
this not too high not too low and a beat
here at the middle of the road season
two may 16th on 2017 was the release
date so a very very long time ago but it
was season two shadow of might which
included such things as two new
characters shinobi and Centurion with
unique move sets and styles sent also
got nerfed three days into release so
I'm pretty sure that's a world record
for that as well as new emotes like the
grape emote the heel kick for shougo key
and the walking the dog emote for
conquer those were all included within
this season these were not as great as
some others that we will be getting
later in the future but at the time
these were the only ones I really had
and they were really crazy cool and
judging from the comments on those
videos a lot of people did agree that
you're got a changes
well and gold gear was also added and
the drop rates were changed to balance
stuff out and make things a little bit
better this is also around the time the
devs realized peer-to-peer servers
weren't working and needed to change the
dedicated servers this wasn't
implemented in season two but it would
definitely come a lot later but it was
still coming around that time at this
point articles ended up bashing the game
for its low player count but weren't in
one shot glitch existed which was
patched within two weeks this was used
by G being the opponent out of lock and
then locking and throwing a heavy at the
same time and for some odd reason the
game counted this as a plunge attack and
allowed you to one-shot the opponent
using worden and then the for honor
blackout and whiteout had also existed
around this time which is something
battlefield players I believe did too EA
to boycott the game by now playing for
24 hours so that's what we also did as
well so that we could get more balanced
as well as a quarter penalty system to
stop afk farming and overall this is all
the stuff that happened in season 2 it
was a pretty good season and it's gonna
be going into sea tier though for the
lots of problems that had occurred and
like I previously stated some of the
character balance at the time wasn't
great all the old players know that
season 2 Centurion and the horrors that
came with it so that is the reason it'll
be going in sea tier season 3 was then
released on August 15th of 2017 which
included another two characters
Highlander and gladiator new sets of
weapons and armor and mythic outfits for
characters as well as there was also a
free weekend for players that were new
and two multiplayer maps including
Sentinel and Viking village damn
sentinels that old holy [ __ ] ranked was
also in the form of duel tournament and
was released and it was very popular
among the community although there
wasn't exploit users would use by
leaving the game to count your match
invalid two others and the other person
would lose which this eventually did get
fixed but it was abused heavily in
ranked although for me it wasn't used
against me a lot although I did play a
little bit in the lower ranks I really
wasn't that great in season 3
it was mostly up in the higher ranks and
like I said in my experience and never
really happened to me too much on top of
that tribute was also released during
this season a very unique twist on the
capture the flag game mode and it still
remains in the game to this day but it's
dead on most platforms in regions sadly
we also had the very first event which
is a Halloween event Feast of the
Otherworld one of the many events we
would get in for honor just like most
events though it included event theme
cosmetics emotes effects in mascot
it's sadly at this time we didn't get
many weapons and execution and related
content so very later in the event soon
to come but for right now this was all
we got and it was honestly a really good
season one of the shining moments of
foreigner in its early days and I got to
give it a Yank our Musha and shaman were
the next two characters released in
season 4 we also got two new maps market
town and gauntlet gauntlet being another
map that I thought was way older than it
actually is new ornaments and the
introduction to 4 executions as opposed
to 2 and our hot bar which was really
really nice as the ability to now hold
the button instead of just tapping it
gave us two more executions to use also
I believe this was the release of teal
gear which would be the last one we
would be getting even until today and I
think the rep cap was also increased to
40 around this time HP used to also
regain your health lower than 1 bar up
to 1 bar but now that was completely
gone from the game and it hasn't been in
there since rank Dominion also came out
in season 4 and the new event frost wind
festival was also released this came a
new winter themed mask outfits effects
and weapons some I still used to this
day as well as patch 1.18 which helped a
few characters get a few buffs and nerfs
Conchas well which at the time conk was
trash so this was received a little bit
negatively on that side there were a few
new game modes ice brawlers with a whole
new map that came with a grand guard
just for it which was that where the ice
would crumble beneath you as well as
dance of death which would return in the
future seasons to come and also get an
innovation in the future as well
season 4 like I said it was a pretty
nice season it wasn't terrible but in my
opinion it wasn't all so monumental
which is why it'll also join in season 1
and being the B tier season 5 was the
start of year 2 of 4 on ER around
February of 2018 and this was a massive
overhaul to the game XP boosts refined
gear were introduced the game for the
very first time the rep cap was
increased to 50 faction war got unique
strategies added to the map and also the
ability to have new effects for
different stuff was also added so you
can now have different effects for your
idol emo and execution and including all
that other stuff I believe you could
have 9 different effects on one
character which was really cool this is
also the season where map updates that
would continue a trend in the future for
either what people would call baby
proofing ledges or getting or adding
more ledges and other stuff like that
this was the start of where this
happened as well as the hero trials the
end the training mode and the new duel
map
this also included new emotes for the
DLC characters and a lot of executions
including the dragon palm strict forearm
Musha the Viking backbreaker 4 Raider
and many many more the new weapons also
came out as well which is once again
more stuff that I have been using still
to this day it's definitely one of my
favorites parry changes were also made
so that GB wasn't guaranteed anymore it
is now a heavy on light parry and a
light on heavy parry yes some characters
can do zones and other moves but that
was really the main gist at the time and
this was also the first season without
characters being added into the game and
the very first iteration of reworks the
first characters to get Reavers for
Kensei conquer and berserker with no
bushi and highlander receiving not
reworks but major balance changes
regardless for the rooks the most
notable changes was that Kent State
would receive pummel strikes and
nature's wrath his lights also did less
damage but added more damage to the
heavies top heavy finisher was also
unblockable and could be fainted into
canceling into gb dodge or soften into a
new move etc so strike and Helms footer
also got some changes as well and his
zone was a three hit attack and it still
is to this day conch had charged heavies
and those were now changed and I believe
they were now unblockable he also had a
bash but he could use as a soft thing
and then an uppercut moved from full
block which I absolutely hate mr. Kerr
could also change heavies into lights
and keep this unlimited combo until they
ran out of stamina with a top heavy
being unblockable you also had to press
a guard break from his deflect as
opposed to just letting it go like it
used to be and happen automatically you
now had to press G B for that Highlander
and no boot like I said had major
changes but not rework potential Celtic
curse was able to cancel into offensive
form very quickly as well as more
stamina damage changes and caber toss
tracking being fixed the bushes kick was
faster but her zone was nerfed and for
the damage she could be G beat if she
missed the kick to make it a little bit
more risky 90% of the stuff I had just
mentioned was actually on release as
well afterwards we got a Valentine's Day
effect after a couple weeks and the best
event to ever touch this game a polygons
legacy was released come and got some
crazy new weapons armor
colors outfits apollyon was the
announcer new emo new mask outfit and a
great new game mode to fit it test your
mettle which was a 4 before elimination
against the story bosses of for honor
which got progressively harder each week
ranging from one
two three lastly for the game was the
introduction to road maps for the dev
streams the house champion mythic
outfits which are some of the
community's favorites they only come
around once every so often and they
always disappear within a week and I
believe at the time that I am actually
making this video the house champion
stuff is actually back so if you haven't
got it you should definitely get it as
well as the drinking and the salt emotes
to follow a couple weeks later which
would create so much salt and toxicity
in the game from wants to come with of
course more mythix and more content not
much to say here pretty much an easy
ester season 6 was another round of
rebirth
Orochi and peacekeeper the usual weapons
and executions were available the
weapons were solid had but had a more
gold look to them the roofs were nice
adding Orochi to do storm rush from all
different angles besides the side and
can be used in chain attacks Riptide
strike was now faster and he also had
400 m/s lights PK could stack bleed and
had many more changes with her lights of
also being 400 and 500 milliseconds
which disappointed a lot of people
because those are pretty quick dagger
cancel was now only from the top and not
where your last heavy was which helped
her which is also stolen to her kit this
day but honestly it's not that hard to
block it as well as GB fainting or dodge
fainting her heavy attack and her zone
was less damage but I believe the same
speed the cover art was also the same as
last season but it's a bit more green
and swampy which in my opinion really
wasn't too great the new map was
beachhead a Dominion map of the Viking
theme they also fixed inventory with the
possibility to transmog our gear and
change the look without worrying about
stats on armor and making a vent armor
not shitty because unless you were up
one and then you would have to play the
character and then actually get the gear
it was just a pain in the ass so that
was a perfect idea the executions
included ones like shoulder tackle the
very first decapitation execution for
lob ringer the Centurion uppercut and
many more the seasonal event that
released at this time it was the right
of champions which included the usual
weapons effects masks such but the point
was all about world building and lore
and which they really didn't accomplish
the biggest note was a contract order
which was a quote from a female
highlander and there is no female
Highlanders at the game at the moment so
that was pretty bad of course the idea
was great but the execution in my
opinion didn't really settle it too much
the new game mode was carousel of death
which is basically like dance of death
but 4v4 and not to be too
weapons were more gold deemed like I had
stated and the radiance effect was
alright it was more for blinding your
opponents while they were looking at
their screen nothing really crazy
besides that and then the sword and the
stone emote was also released and you
could actually pull it out as the
community had figured out so that was a
cool nice discovery they also had
revamped champion status with this
update as well but the events and the
reworks being a little bit lackluster in
my opinion although some small things
like trends mugging and the executions
made up for it it really wasn't my
favorite and I really didn't get really
hyped with this season so this is
actually gonna be going in d tier and
our first d tier for the video Season
seven was the release of the last works
of the year around this time we got lots
of information on the marching fire
trailer which kind of drew some of the
hype from this season away but more on
that later season seven had reworks
which were Valkyrie and warden warden
shoulder Bosch could be fainted at any
time charge bass was much longer
shoulder bash into G be faint was
removed but you could still hard faint
it valiant breakthrough was added as
well as some heavy unblockable on the
heavy finishers felt got loads of three
hit combos as well with lights and heavy
so light heavy light light light light
and you know you get the gist sweep is a
lot faster and she can outperform the
takedown after the sweep for a lot more
damage shoulder pin also did more damage
as well and in terms of that did she got
a lot more regular damage and other
things for bleed with that as well
secluded keep was added for the new map
it was a non Dominion map so I don't
blame you for forgetting this I
completely forgot this map existed until
I was making this video the new weapons
were golden green colors which is pretty
nice the cover art was the same as
season 5 in season 6 but now really
awkwardly blue for some reason we also
got new rewards at rep 60 which was the
sulfuric sparks which is still
personally my favorite a reputation
reward the new executions included stuff
like the LOB ringer next step the Raider
decapitation the Ken's a headbutt and
more anime Orochi we also got a new
event called the raining inferno an
event based on the meme volcano which
was a volcano that the Knights had
always defended in the faction war and
instead of actually playing the faction
war legitly
we just pretty much tried to defend the
volcano the whole time and since the
nice OSA days volt we just combined the
two together to make the volcano but in
the game it's called Mount Ignace it had
new demon mask outfits a limited time
game-mode effect emotes weapons etc the
mastery cool and some fiery effects
there too but they were all right the
emo hoes was a Hadouken blast reference
which was really nice and the game mode
was a Dominion spin-off with some fire
everywhere if you would contestant
objective so the opponent couldn't leave
and run away which is a really nice I
actually kind of liked that twist the
weapons as you would expect have a fire
redesigned to it the only other thing
that happened that season was loads of
info on marching fire and the signature
leaks that would come in season 8 as
much as I enjoyed season 7 the rich
weren't too solid not many people cared
in my opinion and most of the hype this
season was based on season 8 and not so
much on season 7 so this is going to go
in sea tier the only reason it's not
detailed with season 6 was the event was
cool and made things a little bit more
enjoyable and the executions practically
carried the whole season for me running
off year 2 we have marching fire this
like season 5 was another massive
overhaul to the content within the game
we had four heroes this time more than
year one which had two per season and
then the first heroes all year of year
two because of the reworks these four
heroes T&D Shaolin Usha and JJ were part
of a new faction called the bulb in the
bulan didn't come with a new faction on
the map and still haven't sadly
hopefully they will in the future they
also brought a new game-mode with them
called breach which unlike tribute is
still played even today it's a siege
like for before game mode with defenders
defending the castle gates and Commander
with the attackers trying to overthrow
the defenders and take the castle all
these characters came of course with
their own new weapons arm remove sets
executions emotes just like any other
character which of course we're all very
unique and really cool it also came with
a new permanent PvE mode called arcade
which you could get with the arcade pass
which is updated weekly even until today
not only did the new characters get
armor of course the original cast of 12
characters also got whole new armor and
the year 1 heroes also got variations of
existing armor that they already have
which was excellent cuz we hadn't had
new armor since the season 5 event and
we were all craving for new stuff to get
all the weapons and armor looked crazy
as you would expect and the executions
were just as cool is also the first
edition of maskless heroes like
Berserker PK Nobu XI with having some
exposed faces just like the warden and
shougo key so it was all really cool in
terms of the executions we had some of
the good favorites like the gladiator
head stomp and then the berserker
madeyewlook execution the highlander
execution as well the shaman head smash
and more Orochi anime some maps also got
revamped and
make them look just a little bit better
this season also had two events the
Halloween event returned and frost win'
festival everybody thought was actually
going to return but ended up being an
assassin's Creed event the Halloween
event return of the Otherworld was a
return of the previous Halloween event
it was pretty obvious in the title the
skeletons came back in the game and the
map was covered in green flames with the
return of endless March the weapons were
definitely spooky themed as much as they
could be and the mask outfits for all
the characters at the moment were the
last mask outfits that we'd receive for
a little bit as well as the pumpkin emo
and the return of the wolf emote as well
so it's a pretty cool event nonetheless
the Assassin's Creed event had just as
much content as the previous one the
arcade weeklies were actually different
and every single week would be something
different forget regarding to the events
where you would either fight Etsy or
zuzana and it was really cool and the
game mode had a 1v1 versus Ezio and
Caesar we were tasked with killing the
other commander before the team could
kill yours and it was just a game mode
with that it was very different because
it had all the Assassin's Creed
characters the weapons were nice and
actually having some silver in it too as
opposed to the gold some characters like
shaman and Berserker actually had logos
or straight references to Assassin's the
mask outfit was from Assassin's Creed
Odyssey and one of the best event emotes
ever released which was the leap of
faith and loads of other emblems to use
on the characters an overhaul of new
content new armor weapons executions in
two events you already know where this
is going we have season 9 the very first
season of year 3 and the first season to
carry many trends with it this year and
every other year we're going to be
having one hero and event based off
floor and a bunch of other things
this one was BP or black prior or Vorta
gur whatever you happen to call him
which was also included with a shougo
kiri Rick within the season
jucoky got a health nerf but his heavy
is now variable timing his zone was
changed head but had many changes as
well demons brace was removed from
neutral and can no longer one shot but
you could still do some moves that like
off the walls and jeebies and such
peacekeeper also got some changes as
well but they honestly were correct
weren't too crazy noticeable like a
little damage but I liked two or three
and then a little bit more stamina
warlord also got similar changes to this
stuff as well except that his out of
lock was nerfed immensely because of the
spam ability and that his zone was now
undable as for the executions there was
some really nice noticeable ones like
the Centurion Troy execution this creepy
[ __ ] thing
sooo goki throwing people and wow look
at that more anime Orochi the release
date seasonal weapons were winter theme
which is always nice as well as new
armor for the wolven after release there
was a tribute to Stefan Karl with the
number-one emo so rip Stefan the penguin
walk emote was also included any new
event black priors her post was then
released with the revamp of masks now
called illustrious outfits which now had
a lot more stuff to go with it we also
had lore which is as to why the event
was happening which of course I'm a huge
sucker for Laura which is why I was so
excited for this year the Gamo was on
the new map harbor but another Dominion
spin-off the weapons were silver looking
and some of the best weapons this year
in my opinion of course with the usable
emotes and effects and ornaments we also
got some small one day a little Rabbids
event which was nice to screw around
with the minions were changed to the
Raving Rabbids well we didn't get any
content for it
I was definitely still have a little bit
have a little bit of fun in that and it
was also a nice spin to the game and a
small weekend event of ice brawlers
coming back for just a little bit
although to be fair no one really played
it and it was pretty much dead at least
on PC unreleased so very sad to that one
as for BP he was actually pretty
balanced on launch besides the light
bash like combo that tripped up a lot of
people overall the season was pretty
great there was a lot of nice-looking
gear a lot of nice-looking events BP was
actually not too bad so this is gonna be
going in eighth year season 10 was the
second season of the year with the
introduction of smoker's cough heat so
kiri and season 10 executions had some
really nice cool additions like toe
stabbing glad she'll bash warlord
piggyback shaman I'm not even gonna say
it and pyromaniac are a Musha he took
Carrie well once again wasn't really
overpowered she was received a little
bit well but not as good as BP was still
nonetheless she was doable to fight
against although her hyper Armour is
still pretty much a [ __ ]
Raider and lob ring are also given
rubrics this season la bring her shove
on block was removed they gave him some
combos and some 500 and 400 MS lights
the heavy unblockable had a follow-up
light if you landed it and he backflip
and train move could stop and move if
you were hit during the animation the
zone was also changed and now it's
unblockable after a parry for Rader he
got new changes
lots more saw faints the stunning tap
was then 500 milliseconds and thus
started the train of hate for it which
we'll get into in the future he also had
two different zone attacks the
hang on what he did stampede charge
could be stopped mid attack if hit his
light zones and heavies were also
increased and the weapons were more of a
silver look this time and we're
definitely crazy popular again with
everybody else he do carry it like I
said was very well received but not
nearly as much as BP her customization
was unique as well as the weapons
especially the higher tier gear for
after release we ended up getting the T
pose emotes a rep 70 effect which I
still don't use to this day the light
sabers for a day which is a really cool
looking event and I'm kind of sad that
they still haven't done any effects with
these types of things because it's clear
that they can do them which kind of
depressing Raider was then nerve shortly
after the rework for reasons as you
would expect and then III came around
and we got a trailer sadly about 90% of
the playerbase was disappointed the
event was pretty cool though but III was
definitely supposed to be something
crazy it also sucked that for the devs
didn't even talk all they did was just
show the trailer and that was it
regardless of what you think of the
quality of III the event was actually
really good I had a new event where it
was the new map canopy which sadly is
not Dominion so I haven't played that in
a very long time it had a really nice
looking game order you could farm
weapons and you can honestly beat the
game mode and like a minute if you
played on a high difficulty and the
atmospheres of the creepy which
definitely fit this characters vibes
gave us some nice weapons overall heat
so carry was a really fun character in
the beginning and a struggle to fight
with just like every character but the
event was a nice change of pace so beat
here coming down to the last two we have
season 11 which is the release of Holda
but for the executions they are some of
the best in the game being feat
executions like bomb bringer trap Raider
bow and arrow executions and stand power
Shaolin hold I had some nice emotes and
customization as well personally not too
great for me I thought your home was
pretty boring and I also really didn't
like the customization too much but of
course that's just me there was also the
testing grounds for gladiator warlord
and centurion said still didn't have his
rework but gladiator and warlord would
definitely get those within the season
which is of course a thumbs-up to me cuz
I play a lot of gladiator first off
after release we also got the glowing
eyes effect inspired by the Twitter
thread by a foreigner player and the
official Twitter account in terms of the
reworks we had the small medium and
large or a warlord gladiator and cent
respectively warlord got small changes
to damage in stamina gladiator got a
bamboozle changed light attack speed and
toast that was faster Centurion also got
his cuts
along with charge dead being unconfirmed
after a charged heavy this what this
while cool didn't really mean anything
because the rubric is still not out yet
and it was just in testing ground so it
was only there for a couple weeks so
here's hoping that in year four we do
get something for Centurion the season
eleven event wrath of your man Gunther
was nice it was on the new Viking breach
map it was very similar to breach but
now included a giant hammer that you
could pretty much one tap people with it
was cool for a bit but sadly couldn't
find many games after like a day or two
so I couldn't play much but there was a
giant snake in the map which is really
cool to look at had some nice usual
effects outfits mask outfits executions
and emotes all of which I don't use
anymore besides maybe the execution but
that's pretty stretching it it was cool
but I definitely think the mask outfits
could have been better
the weapons very blue theme which like I
said personally not my type I used but
overall they were pretty solid you're
almost kind of like heat so carry with
the response on release balance with
some negative feedback especially her
being so bash reliant I found her pretty
boring though and her lack of
customization really didn't help overall
the season was cool though but it
belongs in CT and then lastly we come to
the current season of season 12 soon da
has personally for me some of my
favorite customization on a hero I've
seen in a very long time
besides BP of course who easily takes
best customization this year suna is for
sure a close second the finishers and
emotes of course are really really great
the executions this season while not
season 11 tear with defeats season 12
also didn't disappoint pony law bringer
charging Raider belly bump Shugo and ara
Musa the content the season has been a
tree branch kind of stuff for an effect
which is cool but nothing really fitting
with most characters then the teases for
the new event and then the actual event
where we got a giant purple horse the
event game mode was also a PvE so a
little nice callback to the past PvE
modes and how cool they were though
weapons while cool didn't really match
with many characters except for me where
I could finally achieve a full purple
soon da follow my twitch please I'll hug
you if he do the story was nice as well
just like every other season this year
and all of this came together which
makes in my opinion this season a tear
for me and that's the full list I'm
sorry if I was talking a little bit
quickly in some parts this video is like
20 to 30 minutes at least I needed to
cut this [ __ ] down this is a very long
video so if you did
it's at the end of this video definitely
be sure to leave a like thank you guys
so much of course you can make your own
by either clicking the link and filling
it out there or in the comments you
could put your top 3 or your bottom
three and as usual I prefer them inset
for comments because algorithm other
than that thank you for watching the
video this was super stressful to make I
think this is like a 9 to 10 page script
of just me writing stuff down per season
so definitely be sure to leave a like
for that those like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe for new I come for the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the patch notes the leaks if I'm
we get today with everything happening
been the year for honor I never miss out
wonder nothing that subscribe the
channel
that guys take care have a great Esther
day let me know what you guys think
about the tier list in the comments
below with that peace out seen another
video
[Music]
you
[Music]